Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
The head of all Marvel's TV shows under Kevin Feige,
just confirmed that they're turning kingpin
into their street level.
Thanos inside the MCU.
Ahead of Daredevil Born Again and Spider-Man.
For All the upcoming street level, Earth based movies
and TV shows for the next couple of years in the MCU.
Vincent D'Onofrio has also been talking
about how to handle
his character in the movies,
along with the Daredevil character.
So we'll break it all down
because it confirms a lot of theories everyone has had.
Going all the way back to the Marvel Netflix days
when they first introduced these characters.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
We have a bunch of Daredevil Born Again
stuff coming up, a bunch of Echo episodes.
It'll all start setting up everything that's
going to be happening with them in the movies as well.
To this is Brad Winderbaum.
He's the head of all of Marvel's
TV shows under Kevin Feige.
This isn't talking about Kingpin as that street level.
Thanos in the MCU movies, TV
shows is not just for all the TV shows.
This is for everything, Wilson Fisk is kind of like
the Thanos of this street level corner of the MCU.
Is that the case going forward?
Is he is he kind of like what we're building towards?
man, you you you kind of hit the nail on the head.
I can't say too much.
Only that that,
you know, as a chapter in Wilson Fisk's life,
this is a crucial one.
And and sets the stage in some remarkable ways for
what's coming next.
It definitely sounds like Marvel is thinking
what we've all been thinking, especially after seeing
Spider-Man into the Spider-Verse with that
literally larger version of Kingpin in the movies.
Kingpin also works as a ground level villain,
but he also works
is the much bigger movie level Spider-Man villain.
His very first appearance was in Amazing Spider-Man
number 50 back in 1967.
so as you weirder that Marvel hadn't
used him in a Spider-Man movie before now.
but the main reasons why they hadn't done
it yet is mostly because up to this point
there were rights issues
and when Sony started developing the Tobey
Maguire Spider-Man movies back in the early 2000s.
At that time, the Sinister Six villains were perceived
by Sony is more commercially viable Spider-Man
villains in the movies.
in at the time. So much money was on the line.
Like this is the very beginning of the big superhero
movie Boom.
they just started doing the Bryan Singer X-Men movies
and they just started blowing up.
So Sony just perceived the Sinister Six villains
as an easier slam dunk for them in terms of villains
overall in the movies, At the time,
they probably made the correct move
like it was probably right for them
to go with the classic Sinister Six roster.
First Kingpin's abilities in the comics
aren't nearly as flashy.
He doesn't have the same type of special powers
as most of those biologically powered Sinister Six
villains.
end, even though Kingpin uses technology in the comics
for the audience
that Sony was looking to get to the movies
like the younger male audience, even the Sinister
Six villains that were more technology
based were an easier sell for them.
didn't really help that the Ben Affleck daredevil
just did not pan out the way that people expected.
There were some good things about that,
like his daredevil costume was actually pretty solid.
but at that time the daredevil rights kingpin
character were at Fox.
Sony Spider-Man movies were doing gangbusters.
Everybody loved them.
Even though Spider-Man three wasn't as well-received,
they were still earning way, way more money
then the Ben Affleck Daredevil movie, also the Elektra
movie after that did not help matters at all.
though. That didn't help things.
but they use kingpin all the time during Spider-Man
the animated series I would call him
just as big as Green Goblin or any of the other
really major Spider-Man villains during that.
so once they introduced the Vincent
in Off Rio in Charlie Cox versions of the characters
in the Daredevil Netflix series,
it was only a matter of time
before you started seeing them in the movies again.
but then thankfully they sort of reinvigorated
the characters with the Daredevil Netflix series.
They introduced Vincent D'Onofrio as version
Charlie Cox's version of Daredevil
and finally, we had some really good versions
of the characters again.
So everyone started wondering
when we're going to see them in the movies.
in Since their debut, Vincent
D'Onofrio has been talking about fighting Spider-Man
in the movies on the regular.
This is him just last week talking about Daredevil and
Spider-Man teaming up against him in Spider-Man four.
I think people would dig seeing
Kingpin and Spider-Man and Daredevil
going at it in the film and,
that basically confirms Marvel's been thinking
what we've all been thinking this whole time.
Take Vincent D'Onofrio is kingpin
Charlie Cox's daredevil and used in the same way
you used them during Spider-Man,
the animated series in a big Spider-Man movie.
in that's the real reason why Marvel is setting Kingpin
up to be their street level.
Thanos so that he makes sense.
In a Spider-Man movie, he becomes a big enough
metaphorical threat to Spider-Man.
they just took Spider-Man back to ground level
at the end of Spider-Man.
No way home.
He'll always participate in those big Avengers
movies like Avengers five,
But No Way Home was about taking him away
from all those Iron Man gadgets.
The Iron Man made suits resetting him
to a more friendly neighborhood Spider-Man version
of the character.
they might have to delay Spider-Man
4 to 2026 at the rate things were going for that movie.
But that would give them time to release Daredevil
Born Again, which is currently set to release in 2025.
During that part of Kingpin's arc is running for
and winning the office
of Mayor of New York City,
running on an anti vigilante campaign.
You kind of see where this is headed, using his powers
and influence as mayor to go after people
he deems as, quote unquote, dangerous vigilantes,
but secretly using the police to just take out
all the heroes like Spider-Man, Daredevil, Punisher,
anyone who would stop him from running New York City,
like his own personal playground,
doing whatever kind of shady stuff that he wants, Yet
imagine Kingpin running on the trust bro
slogan give your vote to Wilson Fisk for mayor.
Seriously trust bro. It'll be great.
And basically turning New York City
into a police state in the process.
It's like part of this big dark rain arc that Marvel
is engineering in the movies and the TV shows.
During Marvel phase by a much more ground level
kind of phase.
Like there are a couple cosmic movies
that are happening in Marvel Phase five,
but a lot of that stuff is mostly Marvel Phase
six stuff
know, a lot of you during Spider-Man,
No Way Home were asking when Matt Murdock, Spider-Man.
Quigley had their team up briefly
at the beginning of that movie.
If Spider-Man now knows who Daredevil is
or if he figured out Matt Murdock was Daredevil
when they were meeting together.
We know.
Before Doctor Strange's two spells, Matt Murdock
for sure knew Peter Parker was Spider-Man.
That was the whole reason why he was helping him out
as a really good lawyer,
because he'd been outed as Spider-Man.
But the final spell at the end of the movie
erased all that knowledge from everyone's minds.
So after the spell, Daredevil
would only know that there is a Spider-Man out there
Webslinger around New York City
trying to help people just like him.
But at least up to this point, we don't know that
they've actually encountered each other at night
while they're in their suits.
Like Daredevil in Costume
has never run into Spider-Man in costume.
they'd probably want to have a meeting like that,
like that first actual meeting
in a post-credits scene
or like the very beginning of Spider-Man four.
Make it like a really big moment.
And then they can have some funny moments
of realization when things go from super serious,
like they almost wait out fighting each other
for a hot second until Spider-Man realizes that it is.
Matt Murdock Like, you sound just like the lawyer
who helped me a while ago,
but Matt Murdock doesn't know that it's Peter Parker,
and he has to convince them otherwise.
Like, No, no, no, seriously,
you just help me out in Daredevil and Spider-Man,
both have a long history
of teaming up together in the comics.
They're team up episodes of Spider-Man.
The animated series were also based on a lot of those.
seriously if you've not watched that TV series,
you could just go back and watch a couple
of those episodes, like watch a couple kingpin
episodes, watch a couple of Daredevil episodes,
you know, give you a good vibe
for what they're team ups would be like.
inside the MCU?
The reason why they team up against Kingpin?
Likely because they both encounter
a kingpin in different parts of New York City
in the crimes that they're investigating him
for are just connected
like Daredevil has been building a case against Kingpin
since the events of Daredevil born again.
In Spider-Man uncovers some other shady thing
that he's involved in in another part of the city.
the wall on the case, Daredevil
and Spider-Man just happened to run into each other,
leading them to their team up.
end, while they're
together, Daredevil can give Spider-Man more sage
wisdom, Daredevil style.
Like that's kind of his thing.
Give him another great power,
great responsibility kind of speech.
But in a daredevil kind of way.
and really the only thing that they have
to do on kingpin side of things is just elevate him
to a more powerful position of authority inside
New York City, which is basically making him mayor.
let me know in the comments how you want them
to actually get kingpin ready to be a movie level
villain like he's mostly there, but
they're just like a couple of things they have to do
for the character, Renner Just based on everything
the Marvel TV people in the Marvel movie,
people are saying, I'm not expecting any Spider-Man
cameos in Daredevil Born Again,
just because so many Marvel are so weird about where
they let Tom Holland's Spider-Man cameo in the movies.
They're probably not going to let him cameo
in any of the TV series,
that's actually one of the reasons
why that friendly neighborhood
Spider-Man TV series we're going to be getting later
this year is going to be elseworlds.
Originally, it was going to be Spider-Man
freshman year based on Tom Holland's Spider-Man
freshman year in high school, like his first year
as Spider-Man, getting the spider bite.
Everything that happened with him
before the events of Captain America Civil War,
when he was in that first homemade suit.
But then they changed the plot, made it
Elseworlds started switching some of the characters,
like they put Norman Osborn in it.
Harry Osborn, Nico from Runaways, Doctor
Strange is going to be in.
Charlie Cox is
Daredevil is also going to be played by Charlie Cox.
Obviously.
so you can see that
Marvel already has a Daredevil Spider-Man team up
with Charlie Cox's version of the character
or close to a version of his character.
So it sounds like they've been planning
on putting him in more movies for a long time.
one of the other best examples of was Spider-Man
versus Kingpin would actually look like, is Spider-Man
four game?
Like there's a really big kingpin battle
at the beginning of that first game.
We don't know who the actual main villain
the Spider-Man four is going to be,
but let me know who you want them to use.
If it's not going to be kingpin,
and kingpin will just be like a secondary villain.
we're supposed to get multiple seasons of Daredevil
born again.
So I'm not expecting Daredevil or Spider-Man
to completely
take Kingpin down by the end of Spider-Man 4.
I think that during Daredevil born again season 2,
he would still be mayor of New York City.
And that's not going to happen till
well after Spider-Man 4 comes out.
there's a whole bunch of related stuff
that's coming up, like we're getting echo episodes
with Daredevil and Kingpin next week.
I'll do a couple videos for that.
We have X-Men 97 episodes
that are coming up after that.
I cannot wait to see more X-Men stuff happening.
The live action movies, too.
We're going to get that Deadpool 3 trailer
at the Super Bowl, Whatever they wind up releasing.
Of course I'll do videos for it.
So click here for that brand new Daredevil trailer
where they confirm all the Marvel Netflix stuff
is canon to the MCU.
And click here
to learn more about Spider-Man four in live action.
Miles Morales, Thank you so much for watching.
and I'll see you guys in the next one!